Anyone who has ever tried to reason with a
sleepwalker knows they can seem to be awake,
yet have bizarre and irrational behaviors.
Stubborn during the best of episodes, and
inconsolable, unreasonable and intense in
the worst, it is not hard to imagine these
walking dreamers acting out nightmares, and
unintentionally turning violent.
In fact, the sleepwalker’s lack of intent
has been used successfully as a defense in
several shocking murder trials over the years.
One of the earliest known sleepwalking murders
was committed by Albert Tirrell in October
1845 in Boston, Massachusetts.
His mistress, Mary Ann Bickford, was found
dead in her seedy boardinghouse.
Her throat had been slashed (6 inches across
and three deep), one ear was cut and an earring
was missing, her skin was charred and her
hair was singed.
Her killer had set her bed on fire.
Tirrell was a wealthy and married man who
had taken to carousing with Mary years earlier
(although both were, at the time of her death,
only in their early 20s), and their relationship
was known to be tempestuous.
On the night she was killed, Mary had been
seen with Tirrell, although he had left by
the time she was discovered.
Witnesses testified that he obtained a ride
hurriedly that evening, and had sought out
relatives for assistance with leaving Boston.
His brother-in-law testified that Tirrell
said he was fleeing from an earlier charge
of adultery, and seemed surprised to hear
of Mary’s murder.
At his trial, Tirrell’s able attorney used
several examples from history to explain how
capable, yet unaware, sleepwalkers could be.
He also presented testimony from Tirrell’s
family about the extent of Tirrell’s somnambulism
since a young age.
After two hours of deliberation, the jury
returned a verdict of not guilty.
On May 24, 1987, late in the evening, Kenneth
Parks, who had fallen asleep in his living
room, abruptly rose, put on his coat, grabbed
his car keys and left his house in Toronto,
Canada.
On his way out, he left both the front door,
and the door to the garage, open.
He drove about 14 miles to the home of his
in-laws, Barbara and Donald Woods.
He was planning on attending a fun family
event there the next day, and all agreed that
before the evening of the killings, he had
a good relationship with his in-laws and had
no motive for hurting them.
After he entered their home, the Woods tried
to restrain Parks.
He then strangled (but not to death) Donald
and bludgeoned and stabbed Barbara many times,
causing her death.
While committing the crime, he severed every
flexor tendon on each of his 10 fingers.
As he left their home, he was observed by
the Woods’ teenage daughters who heard him
grunting like an animal.
Later that night (or early morning), he went
to the police station and told them, “I
think I killed somebody.”
At his trial for murder, the defense presented
his well-established history of sleepwalking,
which ran strongly in his family, as well
as the other facts of the case, in order to
establish an automatism (sleepwalking) defense.
He was acquitted of murder, and that judgment
was sustained on appeal.
On or about October 30, 2003 in Manchester,
England, Jules Lowe, 32, beat his 83-year-old
father, Edward Lowe, to death.
The two men resided together and were known
to have a close relationship.
The evening of the beating, the two had gotten
seriously drunk after they had attended Lowe’s
stepmother’s funeral.
Lowe reported that he had fallen asleep that
night and had no memory of anything until
he discovered his father dead on their driveway
the next morning.
The investigation revealed that the assault
spanned three floors of the home, and that
Edward had 90 distinct injuries.
The jury found Lowe not guilty by reason of
insanity, and he was detained under a hospital
order.
The three people identified above are the
exception, as most people who try to use the
automatism defense are unsuccessful.
One notable murder, where the facts are (at
least to me) as compelling as some of those
where the killer was acquitted, happened in
California in 2001.
After a night of drinking, cocaine and fun
in a hotel room on Catalina Island, Stephen
Otto Reitz, age 25, awoke and found his girlfriend,
Eva Marie Weinfurtner, dead from several stab
wounds to the back of her neck.
When reporting the death to the police, he
noted that although he had no memory of attacking
her (he did have a dream of struggling with
an attacker), the knife wounds to Eva were
similar to those he used in his work (he was
a shark fisherman).
At his trial, it was revealed that Reitz,
who was bi-polar, had forgotten his medication,
but took some anti-anxiety medicine Eva had
given him.
In addition, he had a history of sleepwalking,
and a later investigation at a sleep clinic
showed not only that he suffered from sleepwalking,
but night terrors as well.
Regardless, he was convicted and sentenced
to at least 26 years in prison.